okay [ __ ] we are [ __ ] back make
sure I wasn't set up together again
again what the [ __ ] is this okay
I'm on air like I think we're about to
[ __ ] go outside let it out
holy [ __ ] Hannah find out what happened
I sure would like to get back on that
let's get on it Michael
holy [ __ ] a little tricky
hello I'm Becca guys and get snapchat
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I got let's go here we go
look like and learn the controls
everybody do it [ __ ] okay okay
these are the same kind of controls
[ __ ]
[Music]
does anyone know exactly where I'm
supposed to Vega up yes yes
my car gallon space so that works I
weigh how's that work a lot of corpses
alright I guess I'll just deal with this
all right I'm down hey guys okay a lot
of you folks out here [ __ ]
[Music]
so where we going all around
Oh what is that better yeah that looks
pretty fine out here
this [ __ ] is all [ __ ] up
yeah okay
all right let's do okay there's the guy
we need well done okay any other [ __ ]
down here
what is that be cool actually
[Music]
what is this what is this bridge Kelsey
[ __ ] is this
okay where was this to get back
Hey
what's going on right there
okay hi
press X sine snapchat I'm snapchatting
and I get it this way doctor Kalina
workshops in your turn with a fucked-up
[ __ ] god oh [ __ ] this happen now and we
use a neuro mod any out leverage yep
okay where's the hacker arms off chef or
what is that yeah [ __ ] outta here
what is that what is that just object it
stopped flies yes your answer yeah I was
right there so just [ __ ] it did that
[ __ ] with that
five days on out [ __ ] oh I have two
inches now snap yes anything is a
Taliban with us batch right here
that's [ __ ] I'm gonna put in here I
guess somewhere there's gum
yeah yeah okay go on to the work shot go
to the workshop yes of course I'd like
okay
you think shade a hand
the [ __ ] it is no power
[ __ ] is that what the [ __ ] is that
oh [ __ ]
okay [ __ ]
before use that let me just check
everything climbed up how to show you
okay [ __ ] it
look video to send sure touch base one
which is a lot [ __ ] up
on a date
this is the one that's [ __ ] up
nice work Morgan the looking-glass
screens are online again head back to
your office as soon as you can it's
important you hear the rest of your
message I'll meet you there
it's running light bill capture looks a
little hot
where's the photometer the handheld did
you take it
no ah yes the day we had to now I can't
find one we've only ever had water so
cool
nonsense I guess you forgot no [ __ ]
way you're leaving I thought we were
done
yeah just just doing it often I feel
like you're upset with me
no I I suppose it's it's late after all
now go go are you asleep
what about you what about me yeah I
don't concern yourself
I'll finish right I guess I'll see you
later then yeah you guess what you're
always saying I guess that worked I
guess I'll see you later I guess you're
a scientist stop guessing
no I'll be quiet there that's all
goodnight dr. Covino an obese cup on it
okay
and I'll take their spare parts that's
it before it any okay let me get the
[ __ ] out of here
so he's just going to hit the fan then
let's get on it oh [ __ ] this is the room
with that [ __ ] where is it
[ __ ] it I'm running
[Music]
never mud nothin
that kind of skips it there
what the [ __ ] is this
Plus that on here okay
and I want that [ __ ] recycle over here
we go we want this [ __ ] I should have
stayed all this stuff thank you thank
you okay that's enough of that sex
how does he did kill his dear that - do
that
miel hey this is dr. Calvino what's up
I'm feeling ill not myself today I think
I won't be in for my shift at all okay
do you still want me to finish this
array i fabricated a [ __ ] on a glass
honey
I don't recall you asked me to set up a
new array you must have misunderstood
are you honestly I prefer if you left my
experiments alone in my absence
oh well look I have a message you left
me seriously I would not have made all
of this if you hadn't no no of course I
I remember down let's just for the time
being the IE it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter let's talk about you
tomorrow okay
is he gonna like say now
okay [ __ ] it
Oh No I don't know if I could go up the
stairs for me - OH
a little sex ware thing okay let's see
here let's see here how do you
well Alan's gone from yes I am sure I
can either share with a phone call be
right back